make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering decease part two
and you guys can probably tell I'm a
little under the weather and people who
are familiar with my vlogging channel
will know what it means when I say I'm
having one of my bad days but the show
has to go on so I'm gonna try to make
the best I can out of the way the day's
going so far hopefully it improves later
on I'm trying to work my way through it
so wish me luck but in the first decease
really DC's unkillable video we had
essentially covered what we're the guys
who were left behind right so you have
like Vandal Savage in his forces who
won't recover again in this video but
this initially picks up with like Jason
Todd and Jim Gordon and Cassandra Cain
and a few of the characters here and
there and the long and short of this is
that when they were basically making
their escape from Gotham City did they
end up finding themselves within the
confines or at least you know edit
essentially what was an orphanage right
a place where you had caretakers and he
had kids and there were a lot of the
people who were there and that's that's
one of the weird things is Tom Taylor
kind of builds this idea that there are
like these little pockets here and
they're right where there's just the
people who were left behind right by
whatever manner in whatever means the
folks were left behind and there was
really kind of the criticism of
superheroes right that when it came down
to it the superheroes more or less just
abandoned the earth and just took off
into space and called it a day the
results of this is that when it comes to
Jason Todd and what comes Jim Gordon
along with the the other members who are
here what you end up having is these
caretakers and children who have
basically been kind of locked away in a
room you know where the zombies are more
or less been been kind of taken to that
location now presumably somebody else
put them there but regardless of the
situation the the discussion of Jason
Todd is we have to take these guys out
right we have to we have to get rid of
all these undead people in here and it
makes the most sense in this instance
like they're really a liability having
all these dead people here is basically
a liability and could potentially end up
you know with mass casualties if they
somehow managed to break free the issue
with this is that Jim Gordon doesn't
want to do it right Jim Gordon doesn't
want to have anything to do with taking
out innocent people but the reality of
this situation is that it's it's kind of
the reverse of utilitarianism right I
mean kind of well not really the reverse
but kind of a skewed perspective on a
normal circumstances you say the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few it's just the way that it is you
know and that's in this situation if we
were to say that there's a lot more
people who were surviving then there are
people out there you know people who are
locked away in that room who are dead
and just take them out but this sort of
twist the scenario right because it's
not alive people versus alive people
it's alive people versus dead people or
not really even dead people just
anti-life people and so at the end of
the day there are more anti-life people
than there are survivors but there are
direct hindrance to the survival of the
survivors right so getting in the way of
their ability to live is the biggest
problem they have they have to be taken
out the other part of this equation is
that they're currently in this building
when the SOS goes out from all the
superheroes from Lois Lane who basically
says we're broadcasting on every device
that we can you know within hours we're
gonna leave Earth but we have two
sanctuaries we have Gotham City and then
we've got the mascara make it to one of
those we'll pick you up and then we'll
all we'll all basically vacate and the
result is that Jim Gordon says no like
we're not gonna go we're gonna stay here
and we're gonna protect these people as
best we can now the reality is that Jim
Gordon doesn't really have a plan
assuming that the superheroes leave
earth for a rightful reason which is to
say the earth really is doomed then
essentially he's doomed them all to
death right so all he's doing is
delaying the inevitable
but the reality is that it just makes
Jim Gordon feel better that kind of
seems to be the case and so the result
is that basically you know all those
guys end up staying behind that from
there you end up switching over to the
forces of Vandal Savage specifically
with mirror master and Lady Shiva
now of course Lady Shiva has a lot of
you guys who were familiar with DC
Comics know is the mother of Cassandra
right that's the she's the one that the
the really kind of major made her a
prodigious fighter in a lot of different
ways and so when she shows up here you
know with the help of mirror master you
know initially she tries to get
Cassandra to join up but again Cassandra
is part of the bat family and her time
on the bat family it's harder to
basically fight for the innocence right
and so as a result of that ultimately
she basically says no like I'm not
really I'm not going anywhere I'm
staying here and the reality is that
it's really the smartest move to leave
right because it's one of these things
right I'll allow many of you guys ever
saw the movie predators but it was a
really good scenario where I think Danny
Trejo is character it wasn't Danny Trejo
um I don't know who it was but he was
talking about how they would basically
use injured people in order to Corral
others in right they would they would
basically booby trap them the others
will come to help him and then when they
carry him away basically he's a
liability now he slows everybody down
and so it's the easiest way to take out
a huge group of forces is to start
injuring some of their number and due to
their humanity and their kindness
they'll care for the weakest people
which in turn will make them all weak
and easy targets and that's how that's
how Lady Shiva sees it right if they're
here and they're there deciding to fight
for the lives of other people and so on
and so forth they're not worried about
preserving their lives they're fighting
double duty and as a result of that it
slows them down on all fronts right
fighting a war on
front it's much easier to do than
fighting a war on like two or three
fronts right just ask the Germans during
World War two but the fact remains here
that regardless of the scenario you end
up having a course Jason Todd who kind
of who intervened that says what in the
hell is going on here and you got Jim
Gordon who shows up and so on and
ultimately Cassander does basically
again kind of reiterates it says I'm not
going with you but I'm staying here I
was staying here with my family I'm not
going to some place and leaving
everybody else behind so the results of
this is switching back over to Vandal
Savage with everybody what we end up
finding out is the idea of taking mirror
master or using him as it means to get
her to her daughter is a big no-no and
the reason why is because the reality is
is mirror masters probably one of the
most capable characters out there he's
not the most powerful but he's one of
the most capable because anytime there's
a mirror or a window he can pass from
one location to the next right he can be
anywhere at once like any anywhere in
any location in the world
it's just how his powers work and that's
why I always thought the mirror master
was probably one of the most underrated
characters in all of DC Comics but the
idea is that Vandal Savage sees mirror
master as their escape plan right that
if things pop off if somehow they're
there areas invaded that mirror master
can take them all into a mirror and then
take them to that kind of nexus of
mirrors and then they can come out
anywhere else right but it's the escape
plan right because people can't really
follow mirror master once he passes
through then you're done there's no real
way to get anybody through anymore if he
doesn't take you you don't go and so as
a result of that Lady Shiva of course
kind of gets a stern talking to you
about you know all right this is this is
an issue and so on and so you know as a
result of that we end up having
basically Deathstroke who kind of chimes
in and then almost kind of takes a sort
of leadership role you know not really
you're serving it from Vandal Savage but
taking on this role of like look we
can't all be fighting each other right
you know so because of that Vandal
Savage basically says hey man like you
know I need you to come with me there's
something I've been meaning to show you
and then in turn we basically end up
finding out that what Vandal Savage has
been doing has been experimenting on
people who were immune to the anti-life
equation right who were immune to the
anti-life buyers kind of breaking them
down trying to figure out how it works
and that's what he intends to do with
Slade Wilson right with Deathstroke
literally he has Solomon Grundy knock
him out in the idea is to basically
figure out why it is a Slade Wilson is
immune to the anti-life virus so that in
turn all the other forces can as well or
possibly even just Vandal Savage and
possibly even spread the immunity across
the world and again this is another
example of utilitarianism right if it
really is the goal of Vandal Savage to
save the world using the healing factor
of Deathstroke then it makes them
sense to kill Deathstroke his sacrifice
will save the world sorry about your
luck is just the way it is and not all
instances of utilitarianism require your
consent right that's just the nature of
things right this basically leads to his
daughter Rose kind of jumping in and
taking out Vandal Savage because if you
guys recall she can kind of see glimpses
of the future but it's not an absolute
thing it's really mathematical
probability based on the situation but
her gamble pays off right she shows up
she stabs Vandal Savage in the back and
then in turn solomon grundy you know
gets called a call to his aid and then
solomon grundy you know begins to kind
of step up and then rose realizes okay
we got to get out of here and the reason
why is because again she had kind of a
glimpse of the future and saw that
Wonder Woman was gonna come smashing
through which is exactly what she does
and the first thing she does is rip
Vandal Savage in half following that
solomon grundy basically gets sent
flying right I mean he's he's already
dead so he can't really die but he's of
course punched and and sent flying
Wonder Woman and turn jumps in and
basically all hell begins to kind of
break loose and so the response is grab
mirror master and get everybody out of
here as fast as they can the cool thing
is that Captain Cold kind of comes in
and manages to slow her down right like
basically just starts freezing Wonder
Woman which is a pretty cool moment but
literally just like get everybody out of
here as fast as you can and so following
that what you really get is you get
solomon grundy rose mirror master who
comes in and then goes back to get
everybody else only for him to be taken
out and so right now you've got an
infected captain cold you've got an
infected Wonder Woman and an infected
mirror master from the ones who were
left of course Bane arrives as well with
the help of mirror master and so on but
with Deathstroke Bane and Lady Shiva and
Andros here you've basically got a whole
bunch of villains with a whole bunch of
heroes and the funny thing about this is
they're essentially able to kind of put
their issues to the side right insofar
as it's like okay in this situation
normally Jim Gordon want to lock them
all up but there is something to be said
about self-preservation but the results
of this is that there's a kind of harsh
situation here you know insofar as Jim
Gordon doesn't want them here but even
Jason taught himself begins to realize
there's kind of a benefit to having them
here because these and Todd's played
both sides he's been the hero and he's
been the villain he's been both of these
roles and so it's kind of a funny theme
because Jim Gordon still kind of latched
on to the way the world used to be he's
socially a kind of a stand-in for people
who just can't accept the fact that like
the world has changed now right things
have changed drastically and they're
still living in the past and so as a
result of this what they end up doing is
you end up having a yo Deathstroke who
basically says okay let's do it needs to
be done I mean initially Jim Gordon is
still again
the idea of the various villains being
here but when Deathstroke takes him
aside and says look man like you lost
somebody obviously he lost Barbara
Gordon we know that as the reader and
the Deathstroke says I lost my son it
really kind of brings together this idea
that there are no more good guys and bad
guys anymore right like these these
lines in the sand these villains versus
heroes it doesn't exist anymore it's
just the living versus the dead and
that's the only thing that matters and
so if any of them are all gonna have a
chance of surviving then they're gonna
have to basically put that crap aside
and then just fight the good fight and
then of course Rose asked the question
what's behind this door and that's
basically when when you know all the
villains are revealed like there's all
these all these you know or I guess all
these guys are revealed there's all
these dead people out here and it's kind
of a crazy thing because they're like
you have to kill them you have to kill
them all otherwise they become a
liability and then the truth of this is
that Jim Gordon is the only one who's
really against it
and so they basically say hey man do I
go to the kids and make up an excuse for
why there's some gunfire but like we'll
take care of this here now this is when
we end up finding out the fate of Billy
Batson right this is when we end up
learning what happened to him and it's
kind of a crazy thing because people
have been wondering what happened to
Shazam and Jason Todd basically notices
him he's just one single kid in the
crowd and Jason Todd simply just says
you know that was Billy Batson but he's
basically dead now and he really kind of
seems to hit on the idea that he was
Shazam at one point in time as that's
why things are kind of wild because
basically they opened fire and they
essentially kill everybody now as most
of you guys know when Billy Batson dies
in his human form of course being unable
to shout the word Shazam he dies you
know the whole concept dies as well now
the powers of Shazam can still be given
to someone presumably those powers
basically leave Billy batts his body and
then travel back to the wizard who in
turn can bestow those powers on anybody
else but it's not like The Incredible
Hulk
right like where you go to shoot Bruce
Banner and The Incredible Hulk will
manifest and basically save Bruce's life
doesn't really work that way right you
know a Shazam is not really autonomous
if he's inside the body of Billy Batson
and he hasn't really emerged yet and so
following that over the course of the
next three months you kind of get this
training montage
right where these these traditional
villains more or less are training the
kids on how to fight right you know it's
not enough to simply take care of them
they have to learn how to fight how to
hold their own that kind of a thing you
get have a bit of a romance going on
between Jason Todd and Rose but not a
whole lot to speak up here right setting
up some plot threads it'll be important
later on but at the moment they're not
super important at all instead what is
up happening is of course you have bane
kind of walking through this hallway
doing this Patrol and then of course he
comes upon ace the bat-hound and then as
soon as that happens mirror master pops
out of
out of a window and then immediately
attacks Bain and then following that all
hell breaks loose mirror master starts
popping up in all these different
windows trying to snatch up kids dead
shot saves one of them Floyd ends up
getting taken you know by saving this
little kid Floyd Lawton basically ends
up dying in the process
everything's literally popping off and
so when they all kind of consolidate
back into a Singler location Cassandra
Cain basically comes in and says we're
all screwed and when the question is why
is because Bane's turn there's like a
word of bingo and it's a Bane went
outside and when they get out there when
they realize the front doors been
smashed down Jim Gordon gets out there
and he takes a look he realizes that
what Bane's done is smashed down the
walls essentially opening the doorway
for all these zombies outside to make
their way in but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to Commerce
explain to make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like again I'm sorry the
video is not usually as enthusiastic as
it normally is I'm kind of going through
a rough spot at the moment ah but I will
catch you guys later peace I want to say
thank you to all of the new patrons who
have joined patreon.com slash comics
explained I want to give a shout out to
Henry young - Elias G David J s Jacob H
Ben John H Jason see Austin s Austin H
James O kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M
Steven Z sloth-like lu-david C John H
lean and mean that guy asked questions
all the time Adam Kage enosis 916 I want
to say thank you to all of you all this
list is growing all the time so you're
joining the patreon
[Music]